cómo van a participar estas cámaras
de lo que pretende hacer esta ley
cuándo nos han llamado terroristas
yihadistas nazis
qué pasa con nuestra dignidad
dónde está el derecho a la no discriminación
de los presos políticos catalanes
que mientras se llevaba a cabo ese juicio
los abogados que los tenían que defender
eran espiados
qué pasa con esa discriminación no pasa nada
catalanes hartos de esta discriminación
decidimos opinar
y para opinar como armas
utilizamos argumentos
papeletas
y la ilusión de un proyecto de futuro
como respuesta
brutalidad policial
vulneración de la constitución un 155
una por ellos policial
judicial y acompañado por él
a por ellos económico
nosotros optamos por la independencia
como única solución real
para acabar con la discriminación
que sufrimos los catalanes
para tener una sociedad catalana más justa
más libre y donde nuestra lengua
el catalán
no sigue utilizada como un arma de ansívola
para que los 2 grupos mayoritaris
thinging votes
a la resta de españa